très goûtu pas trop salée c'est déjà mon
sale et au sel de l'île de ré est celle
qui récoltait à la main l'île de ré donc
on est assez de variétés là une autre
variété qui aussi au piment d'espelette
on va chercher le piment directement à
un petit producteur à espelette donc
nous allons vers le chant qui à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ici nous cultivons
6 hectares de l'inédit clair qu'ils vont
nous donner environ 1 300 tonnes de
pommes de terre qui vont être
transformés sur place
la pomme de terre c'est d'aller dit
claire c'est des vérités qui sont très
forts taux de matière sèche
le taux de matière sèche ce qui va
permettre que la chips vraiment très
consciente tout le process de
fabrication des chips se passe derrière
cette porte
mais pour des raisons de confidentialité
ne l'ont pas voir le process mais nous
allons voir directement les ponots
terres qui sont du genre voici les
pommes de terre qui ont été récoltés en
septembre dernier une partie conservée
en chambre froide et une partie est
conservée ici et nous transformons au
fur et à mesure de l'année moi j'ai
toujours voulu transformer un produit
qui étaient issus de fermes familiales
j'ai cherché cherché j'ai repensé aux
produits que faisait ma grand mère
pendant mon enfance ou à fabriquer des
chips pour les déjeuners familiaux du
dimanche
du coup je me suis dit tiens pourquoi je
ne transformerait pas les pommes de
terres de la ferme
ensuite il a fallu plusieurs mois
d'essai avant d'arriver aux produits que
nous recherchions il le but là c'était
vraiment de d'arriver à retrouver
vraiment le goût de la pomme de terre
est de moins de masquer par le sel
médias ça vient de beauce en latin c'est
l'origine du nom beauce est ce que
voulait goûter